[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je parle 3
non
[Musique]
et dieu merci
je leur demande de
toi
[Musique]
je pars
on clôt
[Musique]
pas tout le
chloé
[Musique]
car je suis homme
toi
[Musique]
soit
chanson
[Musique]
tu es
vacances
[Musique]
le soir
je
[Musique]
toi
je
soir
tout le monde
[Musique]
car je suis à bout
car je
[Musique]
m
soir bourges nous sommes gargantua nous
allons passer une demi heure ensemble
pour le meilleur et pour le pire
[Musique]
je parle de toi en tout la montre tout
le monde me parle de toi je pense de toi
à tout le monde car je suis amoureux de
toi toi à tout le monde
[Musique]
donnez moi du choc de deux mois du
chanteur deborah du champion de football
du champion peu contre ok je me réveille
dans les bois soirée salle de devoir
partie qu'illégale près d'îlots de mois
d avril par la loi jean moulin je
t'oublie pas dans mon cul je mets mon
doigt
je suis je serais trop at war j'écoute
du métal que la france doit quand j'ai
faim je viens je vous fais souvent faim
je vous l'avais dit pas le goût
[Musique]
tenez bon tenez bon tenez moi de chars
donnez m'en donnez moi
[Musique]
rabat
gagné
[Musique]
à
gagner gagner gagner gagner toute la
journée j'ai faim j'ai fait toute la
journée toute la journée toute la
journée
c'est pas
j'ai pas tout
je veux
peu ou pas
mais bon là
ça
un jour
enfin toute la journée
je vends
enfin bouclé
bref j'étais sur la plage au soleil
le bret s'est avancé mme aspergés d'eau
bénite et j'ai prévu il m'avait en garde
raymond du bord de mer en garde les
monts du bord mais il m'a dit j'étais
sur la plage de presse
cette avancée master jai d'aubigné je
bouge je brûle soleil
e
[Musique]
cette avancée aspergés d'eau bénite
je brûle
je voudrais
il m'a dit
regardez mon du board
mon gars de démons
du bord de mer
et je brûle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au soleil
[Musique]
hrg
je veux
[Musique]
vous me
longueur
et monde u20
encore
[Musique]
place au soleil
et j'ai pu les manifs rancart des monts
du bord de mer en garde d'ebon dit
encore
bof
je teste
[Musique]
je fais cela
soler
persée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai vu
le soleil était sa plage au soleil
[Musique]
le creux c'est d'avancer
un génie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hu
là
[Musique]
non
m
[Musique]
non
nobi nobi nobi nobi nobi nobi nobi nobi
nobi nobi
face à la glace
aucune occupy to the mirror en développé
couché
pour préparer l'été des protéines
complexes au petit déjeuner
ok
tanguay
couple
[Musique]
à l'étroit dans ton this year par an
niqueurs sabic cours
je prépare au combat
de lui sauter vos muscles s'immortaliser
numérique compressés en zip
[Musique]
nos coeurs car c'est ce double
narcisse 6 6
[Musique]
non
non plus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
tout
écorché op
la bourse ou
[Musique]
sur herbe
corps parfait l'opinion
[Musique]
tous
à tout jamais
[Musique]
m
a toujours
[Musique]
ou jamais
à tous les pauvres de france
[Musique]
pour l'argent l'argent l'argent l'argent
l'argent l'argent
nico
celle à patrick marco
[Musique]
la syrie a ajouté m
barco pour les chaussures de mamie c'est
la nourriture de son chien la voiture le
permis les cours de judo des gamins la
leaf de valérie et sa collection de
timbres pour rembourser le crédit manger
un peu plus simple maintenant sûr
maintenant
jean
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand
[Musique]
oh
jo
[Musique]
oh
ah ah
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans l'ancien
je
rien
combien
m
on
l'argent
[Musique]
non
tu vois
[Musique]
pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
garage à vélo sans vélo
gary siècle derrière mon dos
[Musique]
quelqu'un qui était la cible
ce quelqu'un là a disparu
[Musique]
une guitare et un banjo
deux ou trois ils mis au bord de l'eau
[Musique]
musique pop
map
[Musique]
ça
on n'ira qu'en
on ira loin
[Musique]
chantant la pluie ma fenêtre et me
demandent si je dois être
un différend touché perdu
ou quelque chose qui t'aurait plus qu'en
défilent à toute vitesse souvenir
lointain de tes promesses
[Musique]
les microphones la voix s'est tue ou
pape a disparu
à
ça
khoza
ça sent en irak quand tu devras sens on
ira loin de tout ça
[Applaudissements]
donc sans dire à ton tour à tour
s'ennuie
[Musique]
non mais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci à tous d'avoir écouté ce soir
à l'ère des ordinateurs à l'air du temps
de 20 heures à l'air du temps bien tard
à l'ère des ordinateurs dieu
[Musique]
à l'ère des ordinateurs à l'ère des
ordinateurs à l'ère des ordinateurs à
l'aise dans cette cité vous dès 18h50
heure alerte amber alert sentir tort à
l'ère des ordinateurs alerte amber à
l'erreur voilà à l'ère du docteur est-il
vraiment nécessaire à l'air intérieur
est nécessaire de croire en dieu
[Musique]
je
tiens
dieu
deux aviateurs flatteur bien peur d'y
perdre entre la part-dieu sens bien
il ya deux jours la bande à part
les rues
chose
à l'ère des ordinateurs
[Applaudissements]